[Música]
eu venho de um bairro chamado vila
missionária periferia da zona sul de são
paulo
meus pais para que o irmão pudesse não
só estudar trabalhava no centro da
cidade
minha mãe como vendedora e diarista e
meu pai como cobrador de ônibus
no entanto essa era a única realidade
que o irmão conhecemos isso mudou com a
obmep
a olimpíada brasileira de matemática das
escolas públicas e com ela uma bolsa em
uma escola privada no centro de são
paulo
eu comecei a viver em duas realidades
completamente diferentes que estavam
apenas a uma hora e meia de ônibus e
metrô
eu percebi o quão desigual a nossa são
paulo
o quão desigual nosso brasil são eu
percebi que essa desigualdade e eu muito
além da renda e não estava apenas na
qualidade e no acesso a serviços como
saúde segurança e educação
no meu bairro onde parecia ser um pouco
menor ea faculdade era muitas vezes um
sonho muito distante na escola onde eu
fui bolsista o mundo era cheio de
possibilidades e se sonhava em ser
médico cientista e advogado descobrir
que o sonho e o tamanho do sonho tem cep
gênero e raça no brasil me encheu de
tristeza
no entanto fez uma descoberta muito mais
importante que assim um caminho para a
igualdade de oportunidades e que esse
caminho é o da educação
quando eu descobri a importância da
educação e eu descobri que eu podia sim
sonhar eu comecei a sonhar muito grande
o meu primeiro sonho foi de representar
o meu país e uma competição
internacional de ciências e depois de
muito estudo foi pra cima em competições
mundiais de química astronomia e
astrofísica
logo depois tive um segundo sonho
grande que era estudar em uma faculdade
do exterior
depois de muitas bolsas muitas pessoas
sonhando comigo acreditando no meu sonho
e realmente me dando oportunidades e
depois de muito esforço foi aceita em
seis faculdades americanas com bolsa e
escolheu a universidade harvard
chegando na faculdade eu olhei para
minha trajetória e olhei para a
trajetória da minha família eu perdi o
meu pai para as drogas e para o álcool
poucos dias depois que eu fui aceita em
harvard ele era uma pessoa extremamente
inteligente e muito esforçada
no entanto não teve nenhuma oportunidade
em sua vida e não chegou a completar o
ensino fundamental
já o meu irmão terminou o ensino médio
em uma escola estadual de são paulo sem
nunca ter tido uma aula de química e sem
sonhar como a faculdade e só aceitou
fazer cursinho depois de muito
convencimento e foi assim com a
oportunidade com um sonho e que muito
esforço que ele entrou na unicamp e se
formando que vem sistemas da informação
[Música]
tudo isso me mostrou que a minha missão
estava na educação e ou trocar de curso
de astrofísica das ciências políticas e
foi estudando educação que eu me deparei
com dados como esse
quando a gente olha os alunos que estão
terminando o ensino fundamental nas
escolas públicas
sete de cada dez não aprenderam o que
deveriam em português ea situação ainda
pior e matemática
nove de cada dez alunos que estão se
graduando ano do ensino fundamental da
rede pública não aprenderam que deveriam
de matemática nove de cada dez
eu realmente acredito que essa baixa
qualidade da educação no brasil se deve
ao fato de educação ser importante na
teoria no discurso mas não na prática
vemos uma população que vai às ruas
pedindo escolas padrão fifa
temos também um governo que se dizia ser
uma pátria educadora
no entanto as decisões desses mesmos
eleitores e desse mesmo governo deixou
muito claro que a educação está muito
longe de ser uma prioridade ea responder
a este problema que surgiu o movimento
mapa educação
nós somos um movimento formado por
centenas de jovens de todo o brasil que
lutam por uma educação de qualidade para
todos fazendo do jovem o protagonista
dessa mudança a gente mobiliza jovens de
todo o brasil para atuarem na
fiscalização de políticas públicas e
também no debate educacional para que a
educação seja de verdade prioridade para
o brasil para os eleitores para os
candidatos e para os governantes na
frente de mobilização jovem agente
realiza pesquisas conferências debates
criando uma ponte de diálogo entre o
jovem eo governo na frente de
fiscalização política realizamos
campanhas e acompanhamos a implementação
de políticas públicas em educação e aqui
eu quero compartilhar duas experiências
dos nossos embaixadores um deles
o daniel é de juarez távora na paraíba
nas eleições municipais do ano passado
realizou um debate educacional entre os
possíveis candidatos a prefeito de sua
cidade
no entanto na última hora uma das
candidatas se recusou a ir ao debate
disse que não havia sido convidada e
entrou com uma ação judicial proibindo
que o debate fosse transmitido pela
rádio mas o daniel é um jovem realmente
afetado e não se contentou com isso ele
foi lá levou o debate para a praça da
cidade e fez história
outro embaixador é o toninho ele é de
sergipe de uma cidade chamada nossa
senhora das dores
no ano passado ele fez uma campanha de
abaixo assinado que fez com que o
prefeito eleito se comprometer se a
mudar a forma de seleção dos diretores
escolares em 85% dos municípios no
brasil
os diretores são escolhidos por
indicação política
isso é uma troca de votos e extremamente
pernicioso para a educação
nessa cidade a partir de agora os
diretores e não escolhi
não mais por indicação política mas por
uma eleição pela comunidade
uma vez me mostrando que a maneira de
você transformar a educação é também
transformando a nossa política e é por
isso que eu sou parte de outro movimento
social eu acredito
o acredito é um movimento nacional e
suprapartidário que busca a renovação
política para que tenhamos um brasil com
igualdade de oportunidades e com
dignidade para todos nós sonhamos com o
novo congresso que tem a cara do nosso
brasil com mais mulheres mais negros e
mais jovens
o acredito está presente hoje em 11
estados ea gente se reúne por núcleos
que basicamente são grupos de pessoas
que discutem política que debatem
projetos e programas e que no futuro vão
escolher a agenda de seus candidatos e
os seus candidatos
na minha opinião a mobilização é um fim
em si só e ver mais de mil pessoas
engajadas e mobilizados politicamente me
enche de esperança
o meu maior sonho é morar em um país que
tenha igualdade de oportunidades e que
garanta uma vida digna para todos os
seus cidadãos
eu acho que isso vai acontecer quando
tivermos uma educação de qualidade para
todos e quando nos engajarmos
transformamos a nossa política mas isso
só será possível se fizermos
transformação com todos e não apenas com
alguns
recentemente eu li um livro que chama
however longo da noite que significa não
importa com o longa seja noite
ele conta a história de uma americana
que depois demorar décadas no senegal
acabou com a prática de mutilação
genital feminina e ela não fez isso a
ponta do dedos criticando as pessoas e
falando vocês são burros vocês não sabem
o que estão fazendo ela fez isso dando
aulas de direitos humanos com as aulas
de direitos humanos às mulheres das
vilas ficaram tão empoderadas que
decidiram escolher um futuro diferente
para as suas filhas também recentemente
eu tive a oportunidade de estar uma
conversa com o presidente obama
além de ser estrela
inspirador e me encher de energia ele
falou uma coisa que me marcou muito
nessa conversa ele disse que mobilização
é você em poder às pessoas para que
escolham seus futuros
e pra mim é isso a gente tem que poder
às pessoas para que elas escolham um
futuro diferente para o nosso brasil
eu realmente acredito que a educação é o
único caminho a ser trilhado para que o
brasil se transforme no país que
queremos
então gostaria de convidá-los a também
trilhar esse caminho e escolheu esse
caminho para o nosso brasil
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]